ينضم الينا الان من بروكسل مفردنا عبد
الله ملكاوي عبد الله صباح الخير ابا معك
مع تصريحات او تحضير زيلينسكي الذي دعا
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى تسريع ارسال الاسلحه
الى بلاده ما تفاصيل هذه العمليه
نعم
يعلم ان هناك مده وفجوه بين القرارات التي
يتم اتخاذها هنا في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبين اليه تنفيذ هذه القرارات
فالاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا اقر بالامس في
يومه القمه الاول لزعماء والرسائل دول
وحكومات الاتحاد الاوروبي 27 اقر الاتفاق
الذي كان ابرمه وزراء الخارجيه والدفاع
يوم الاثنين الماضي والذي يقرب بارسال
مليون قذيفه
لاوكرانيا يتم اخذها من المخزون الاوروبي
مباشره وخصصا مليار يورو لتعويض هذا
المخزون للدول المساهمه بهذه العمليه وخصص
ايضا
مليار يورو اضافيه لشراء مشترك للذخيره
يتم ارسالها فيما بعد لاوكرانيا لكن
الجانب السلبي لهذا القرار هو او الماخذ
على هذا القرار هو ان المليار يورو سيتم
يعني
طلب هذه الذخيره المشتركه سيتم طلبها في
شهر ايار مايو المقبل اي بعد حوالي شهرين
ومن ثم سيتم تجهيز هذه الطلبيه ومن ثم
ارسالها الى اوكرانيا وتجهيز الطالبيه
بالتاكيد والتصنيع سياخذ اشهرا اضافيه
وبالتالي هناك عده اشهر ستمر قبل ارسال
هذه المساعدات او هذه الذخيره لاوكرانيا
وبالتالي لهذا يحذر الرئيس الاوكراني من
ضروره تسريع تسليم الاسلحه لاوكرانيا وعلى
ان يتم شراء هذه الاسلحه
بداخل الدول الاتحاد الاوروبيه المصنعه
بالاضافه الى النرويج وايضا بالامس شددوا
على ضروره مكافحه التحايل الذي يتم على
قرارات العقوبات ضد روسيا وبالتالي
استهداف الدول التي تحاول الالتفاف على
هذه العقوبات كما ايد اعضاء المجلس
الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي فكره انشاء
محكمه دوليه خاصه تعنى فقط
بعدوان دوله على اخرى بالاضافه الى تقديم
جرائم الحرب الروسيه امام المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لكنهم يريدون ايضا انشاء
محكمه خاصه
لاعتداء الدول ضد دول على المستوى الدولي
يعني عبد الله سؤال اخير لو سمحت ماذا عن
لقاء هل من معلومات عن هذا اللقاء
والمواضيع التي قد سيتطرق اليها
اللقاء هو على هامش هذه القمه هذا الصباح
بدا اللقاء قبل انطلاق هذه القمه لكن هذا
اللقاء على الهامش ولقاء خاص لم يصدر اي
تصريحات نحن بانتظار اي تصريحات قد يعني
تخرج من محيط الرئيس الفرنسي مانيويل
ماكرون وفيكم فيها فيما بعد لكن بالتاكيد
هناك نقاط خلافيه بين الدولتين على هامش
هذه القمه تتعلق بالسيارات ذات المحرك
التي تعمل بالاحتراق الداخلي او السيارات
التي تعمل بالوقود والتي تريد المانيا ان
تستمر في بيعها بعد عام 2035 بعكس الاتفاق
الاوروبي الذي يريد ايقاف بيع هذه
السيارات بعد 35 وايضا فرنسا من جهتها
التي تريد ان تكون الطاقه النوويه احدى
البدائل للطاقه التي تتسبب بانبعاث
الكربون لكن المانيا بجانبها ترفض هذا
الشيء لانها تريد انهاء العمل بالطاقه
النوويه وبالتالي هناك نقاط خلافيه تريد
الدولتان الابرز والاهم في الاتحاد
الاوروبي او الركيزتان الاهم في الاتحاد
الاوروبي انت تخطاهما كي يتم يعني تسهيل
الاجراءات والاتفاقات داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبيه وبتاكيد اليوم الثاني اليوم هو
مخصص لليورو للمسائل الاقتصاديه والبنكيه
رئيسه البنك المركزي كريستين الاوروبي
كريستين لاجارد تريد ما ان يسرع
زعماء الدول بانشاء اتحاد بنكي اوروبي
خاصه في ظل الانهيارات البنكيه التي
تشهدها الولايات المتحده وسويسرا مثلا
لتعزيز هذه الحصانه
البنكيه كي لا تنهار بنوك اخرى في اوروبا
في المستقبل عبد الله ملكاوي يا مفادنا
الى بروكسل اشكرك على كل هذه المعلومات